hey guys
thanks for tuning in just a quickie
today so recently I've been forced to
leave my gym which sucks due to
financial and geographical reasons and
I've been relying mostly on bodyweight
training while other kettlebells and and
the gymnastic rings because this fact is
really quite small has a wobbly floor
and every time I doing kind of exercise
the window rattles and the people
downstairs probably don't like you very
much
so I've had to kind of always inventive
ways to workout in small spaces I can't
even do my usual primary clapping press
ups and things but I've got by I've
managed to actually bulk up but the main
thing I have missed is a bench press I
wasn't able to bring my bench press with
me want to move to London I'm had one
for years but at least I had one other
gym now got nothing so for the checks
that I've been relying mostly on those
gymnastic rings and dumbbells but it's
just not the same
so I looked into doing frog presses
which bench presses and barbell from the
floor and I found it didn't work so I
came up with this neat alternative meats
in my opinion that if I share with you
because it might be useful for some
other people the problem with a frog
pressed as you can imagine is just a
bench press except you're lying on the
floor hence the name floor press the
problem with it is getting underneath
the barbell to begin with you can't load
up heavy enough to lift off the floor
because you can't squeeze your body
underneath it and then if you try and
swing it up in the air you're not gonna
be able to do it with a heavy enough
weight that you would want to press and
compress much more than you can
awkwardly climb under and there's a good
risk of you garroted yourself as well so
my mum was getting rid of this this
install from her house and asked to keep
it cause I had an inkling it might be
useful for working out their ages I love
trying to lie on it using it as the
bench itself to press some dumbbells but
then I realized this isn't the bench
this is the rack and I'll show you what
I've come up with so I don't know how
much weight I've gone here but it's
significantly more than I would normally
have to do it progress and voila
observe I can press in it's almost just
as convenient as it would be with a
regular venture fest in fact although it
might look ridiculous this actually has
some benefits even a burr an actual
venture hey for instance because my
head's underneath this table I literally
can't smash my face in or grott my
throat so I am as safe as can be even in
this instance has a couple of not really
bubbled soon as you can see those but he
is slightly cooling it actually stops
the weight from rolling the Commish
david remodeling one it's just heavy
anyways the point is it's not going to
roll off and if you can find like that
then get that this is also obviously
much cheaper than a bench pressing
probably get it's a free cycle you
probably get it from car boot sale for
fiver you know not this exact table but
anything is wide enough you to get
underneath and sturdy enough to hold a
good amount away I mean I've been
standing on this I'm you know pretty
heavy heavy enough then to hold the
weight in this position so yeah give it
a go and floor press has a number of
benefits in itself it forces you to stop
at ninth agreed with your arm which
removes any kind of momentum you can't
bounce it off your chest and some people
like to to cheat and during the gym
because you can't reach your chest at
the same time the limiting the movement
that way you should protect your
shoulders from injury so if you've got a
shoulder injury this is actually a safer
easier way to train your pecs as well so
progress is useful they also going to
improve symmetry because if you come
down with one arm faster than the other
you're going to notice it very quickly
because getting hit the ground just
being me I'll include I'll incorporate
some kind of drop set and let's do it
now and I'll do super sets press ups and
things and between me and this little
bench I've got enough equipment to get a
really good chest workout on actually so
yeah you could also use this for
and run things I'm sure I'll be posting
again with other ideas papers has helped
if it's useful and yeah let me know in
the comments if you have any other
similar little workout hacks I'll post
more as I come up with them see you next
time